jesus maria led the original inquiry
into the disappearance of 43 students
prosecutors say he covered up what
really happened
mexico's president andres manuel lopez
obrador says those responsible must face
justice
i can say of course the case is not
closed the commission's report has been
released and the prosecutor's office
will continue to work on it
uncovering the truth strengthens
institutions and punishes those
responsible
the group of students went missing six
years ago while traveling by bus to a
demonstration mourinho's report in 2015
concluded they were detained by corrupt
police officers and handed over to a
drug cartel which mistook them for
members of a rival gang
it said the cartel killed the students
and burned their remains at a rubbish
dump but the families independent
investigators and the u.n high
commissioner for human rights rejected
the findings
on thursday a day before maria's arrest
mexico's most senior human rights
official referred to a high level
cover-up
the disappearance of the 43 students
constitutes a state crime federal and
state authorities at the highest level
were negligent and altered facts to
establish a false conclusion of what
happened
six years on these families are still
waiting for answers only the remains of
three young men have been identified
mourinho's arrest has renewed hopes of
finally finding out what happened
victoria gatenby al jazeera